[Music]
let's start with a poi su warmup warming
up is important because if you start
spinning your poi over and your
shoulders your elbows and your wrists
and everything else is cold you greatly
increase the chance of injury if you
want to avoid injury it's by warming up
your body and gently taking all your
joints and articulations through ranges
of motion to get them lubricated and
recruited that's how you avoid injury
and we're going to do today's warm-up
using some important play concepts so
first make sure you got some space
around you and always just start by kind
of shaking out and loosening up just
feel your body just wiggle a little bit
you know can you just look don't go to
any extremes don't stretch your neck but
move your head move your shoulders move
your elbows move your wrists move your
knees and your ankles and your hips make
sure everything but to music on and
warming up is about recruiting your
motor skills all your neural motor
coordination and by moving the joints
gently you get the synovial fluid
loosened up which lubricates your joints
meaning the moans won't rub together so
it's really important so a little bit of
bouncing gets some blood flowing you
guys aren't gonna face me and we're
gonna go through some ploy concepts here
circle your wrists inwards so the
fingers are going down the center this
is inward so it's like there's a wall in
front of you so it's like you're moving
your fingers along that wall so we call
this the wall plane and we call this
inwards and since they're moving
together we call it the same time so
your wrists are moving your hands I
guess are moving inwards same time on a
wall plane we'd also go outwards and
very quickly you feel your wrist huh so
let's switch to the elbows
elbows just let them kind of be at your
sides and from the elbows move your arms
inwards on a wall playing and outwards
on a wall playing and notice your
postures now and let your heart open a
little bit stem tall you can keep
shifting the weight from one leg the
other and having rid of a pulse okay
then go even bigger we're gonna go from
the shoulders come in words and notice
you have to choose one arm will be on
top of the other so alternate rights on
top this is the homophone move right
some top left on top right on top left
on top and then go outwards up in the
middle and reverse when they get to your
legs one has to be inside the other my
left is inside my right comes up
underneath you'll see just get them
going
so that's your offices at on the wall
plane we'll talk about wheel planes
opposites another time you can also do
opposites split time that's where you
take turns right left right left right
left chopping down the middle like this
you can do it small from the wrists from
the elbows from the shoulders
you can go outwards from the elbows from
the wrists from the elbows from the
shoulders
so we have opposites inwards outwards
same time inward split time at word
split time this is all on wall plane you
can also take your arms and you can move
them same direction the same time so
they're both going for me it's clockwise
for you it's counterclockwise that's a
mere mean you're going the other way
which for you is clockwise and for me
it's counterclockwise again it can just
be the wrists that can be the elbows it
can be the shoulders go the other way
the shoulders to the elbows to the
wrists let's turn this way
to do that's blue time same direction so
if we face this way together you can
leave your arms forwards and circles and
little circles you can do it looks like
the John Travolta disco dancing or
opening up to be at your sides around
your hips or circles in front of you
like you've got a big bicycle or you can
open it up and go really big like you're
doing a front crawl know what we're
going to do actually gonna turn around
and go backwards and you'll see why in
poi it's about keeping the continue of
movement so if this is backwards
this is forwards and if this is forwards
this is backwards because I'm turning
around like you turn around in a car
you're now going backwards so you can do
little circles John from ulta backwards
bigger circles at the sides really big
circles and just turn and go forwards
don't worry too much - how how you
connect them yet turn go backwards turn
go forwards turn go backwards turn
four words in time we're gonna learn the
loop it all together but we don't have
to do that today so we have opposites
split hem opposites emerge the net words
same direction clockwise and
counterclockwise and split time same
direction forwards and backwards we can
also do things you could do same
direction on the wheel plans this is
wall plane when you're at your sides and
it's more like you're standing on train
tracks we usually call that wheel planes
but the arms don't bend backwards very
well so doing the same direction on the
wheel planes doesn't work very well
nor does doing split time opposites
because of the limitations of the arms
so there's some kinds of movement we do
more on wall playing some kind of move
into you more on wheeler plans and we'll
go over all of that in the coming
lessons but that's got you started let's
recruit your brain as well as your body
and let's move on from our lessons
[Music]